this morning local cox crews are
traveling to the gulf coast to help
restore some critical services needed
there hector mejia is live near rancho
and bonanza with the details i think
it's great that nevada is jumping in and
helping out with some of these
incredible disasters that are going on
around the country hector
[Music]
crews are mobilizing not just here in
nevada but across the southwest really
all across the country from all types of
services this morning it happens to be
six local crews here in las vegas cox
communications crews were heading down
to louisiana this morning in just a few
hours to help with the recovery efforts
joining us live we have joe baker who's
part of the team who's heading out there
who's going to give us a safe
demonstration of what they'll be doing
out there first of all good morning to
you how are you doing good job i'm
getting good this morning so how do you
prepare for something like this you just
pack up and i expect to do your same
duties but just with a lot more
obstacles with the destruction out there
absolutely i expect to be involved in
some organized chaos out there
that's one of the buckets that we'll be
using we'll be driving this down there
absolutely this is my vehicle i'll be
driving all the way out there you guys
are taking six of these plus some rvs
while you guys stay out there for the
next two weeks or so restoring critical
services you guys have employees down
there you were telling me that
thankfully they have all been accounted
for yes that is correct
tell us a little bit about the work
you'll be doing have you ever done
anything like this yes yes and
was prior military been involved in
recovery operations
the folks that have been disheveled out
of their homes disaster areas
not for cox per se but i'm going to be
relying on the training my company has
provided me
just really happy to help
those families in needs out there
employees and customers alike
joe thank you so much we'll be talking a
bit more about their mission of the next
half hour but people need their internet
restored their need they need their tv
services a whole range of services that
they need out there including power too
as they recover from this storm the
hurricane from sunday anyway reporting
live hector mejia 8 news now we'll check
back in with you guys in about half an
hour from now